- [Voiceover] Hello everyone,
what I wanna talk about here
is how to interpret the
directional derivative
in terms of graphs.
I have here the graph of a function,
a multivariable function,
it's f of xy is equal
to x squared times y.
In the last couple videos I talked
about what the directional derivative is,
how you can formally define it,
how you can compute it using the gradient.
Generally the setup
that you might have is,
you have some kind of
vector, and this is a vector
in the input space so in this case
it's gonna be in the xy plane.
In this case I'll just
take the vector 1 1.
Okay? And the directional
derivative, which we
denote by kind of taking
the gradient symbol,
except you stick the name of
that vector down in the lower
part there, the directional
derivative of your function,
it'll still take the same input.
This is kind of a measure
of how the function changes
when the input moves in that direction.
So I'll show you what I mean, I mean
you could imagine slicing this
graph by some kind of plane
but that plane doesn't
necessarily have to be parallel
to the x or y axes.
That's what we did for the
partial derivative, we took
a plane that represented
the constant x value or
the constant y value, but
this is gonna be a plane that
kind of tells you what
movement in the direction of
your vector looks like, and
like I have a number of other
times I'm gonna go ahead and
slice the graph along that
plane, and just to make it
clear, I'm gonna color in where
the graph intersects that slice.
This vector here, this little
v, you'll be thinking of it
as living on the xy plane and
it's determining the direction
of this plane that we're
slicing things with.
On the xy plane you've got this vector,
it's 1 1, it kind of points
to that diagonal direction,
and then you take the whole
plane and you slice your graph.
And if we want to interpret the
directional derivative here,
I'm gonna go ahead and
fill it an actual value,
so let's say we wanted to do it at -1 1,
- 1, -1
'cause I guess I chose a
plane that passes through the
origin, so I've got to
make sure that the point
I'm evaluating actually
goes along this plane,
but you could imagine one that
points in the same direction,
but you kind of slide it back and forth,
if we're doing this, we can
interpret this as a slope,
but you have to be very careful,
if you're gonna interpret
this as a slope, it has to be
the case that you're dealing
with a unit vector, that
the magnitude of your vector
is equal to 1.
I mean, it doesn't have to
be, you can kind of account
for it later but it makes
it more easy to think about.
If we're just thinking of a unit vector.
When I go over here instead
of saying that it's 1 1,
I'm gonna say it's whatever
vector points in the same
direction but has a unit
length, and in this case that
happens to be square root of 2 over 2,
for each of the components.
You can kind of think about
why that would be true
by diagonal but this is a
vector with unit length,
and its magnitude is 1, and
it points in that direction.
If we're evaluating this
negative point like 1 1,
we can draw that on the graph,
see where it actually is,
and in this case it'll be,
oops, moving things about when
I had a point.
It'll be this point and if
you kinda look from above,
you see that's -1, -1,
and if we want the slope at that
point, you're kinda thinking
of the tangent line here.
Tangent line to that curve,
and we're wondering what its
slope is, so, the reason that
the directional derivative
is gonna give us this slope,
is because, another notation
that might be kinda helpful
for what this directional
derivative is, some people
will write partial f,
and partial v.
You can think about
that as taking a slight
nudge in the direction of
v, so this would be a little
nudge, a little partial
nudge in the direction of v.
And then you're saying
"what changed in the value
of the function that's then resulting?"
"The height of the graph, does
it devalue the function?".
As this initial change
approaches zero and the resulting
change approaches zero as
well, that ratio, the ratio
of the partial f to partial
v, is going to give the slope
of this tangent line.
Conceptually, that's kind
of a nicer notation, but the
reason we use this other
notation is nabla sub v 1,
is it's very indicative
of how you compute things
once you need it computed.
You take the gradient of f,
just the vector value function
gradient of f, and take the
dot product with the vector.
Let's actually do that,
just to see what this would
look like, and I'll go ahead
and write it over here,
use a different color.
The gradient of f, first of
all, is a vector full of partial
derivatives, it'll be the
partial derivative of f with
respect to x and the partial
derivative of f with respect
to y.
When we actually evaluate
this, we take a look, partial
derivative of f with respect
to x, x looks like the variable
y I just a constant, so its
partial derivative is 2 times x
times y.
2 times x times y.
but when we take the partial with
respect to y, y now looks
like a variable, and x looks
like a constant, derivative of
a constant times a variable,
is just that constant x squared.
And if we were to evaluate
this at the point -1, -1,
then you can plug that in, 2
times -1 times -1 would be 2,
and then negative 1 squared, would be 1.
So that would be our gradient
at that point, which means
if we want to evaluate gradient
of f times v, we could go
over here, and say that's 2 1,
'cause we evaluate the gradient
at the point we care about.
And then the dot product,
with v itself in this case,
root 2 over 2, and root 2 over 2.
The answer that we get, we
multiply the fist two components
together, 2 times root 2
over 2, then square it to 2,
and then here we multiply the
second components together,
and that's gonna be 1 times
root 2 over 2, root 2 over 2,
and that would be our answer,
that would be our slope.
But this only works if your
vector is a unit vector,
and I showed this in the last
video where we talked about
the formal definition of
the directional derivative.
If you scale v by 2, and I
can do it here if instead of v
you're talking about 2 v, so
I'll go ahead and make myself
some room here.
If you're taking the
directional derivative along 2 v
of f, the way that we're
computing that, we're still taking
the gradient of f, dot product
with 2 times your vector,
and dot product, you
can pull out that too.
This is just gonna double the
value of the entire thing.
V, this started with v, it's
gonna be twice the value,
the derivative will become
twice the value, but you don't
necessarily want that because
you'd see this plane you
sliced with, if instead of
doing it in the direction of v,
the unit vector, you did in
the direction of 2 times v,
it's the same plane, it's
the same slice you're taking,
and you'd want that same
slope, so that's gonna mess
everything up.
This is super important if
you're thinking about things in
the context of slope, one
thing that you could say is
your formula for the slope of
a graph in the direction of v,
is you take your directional
derivative, that dot product
between f and v, and you just
always make sure to divide it
by the magnitude of v,
divide it by that magnitude.
That will always take care
of what you want, that's
basically a way of making sure
that really, you're taking
the directional derivative
in the direction of a certain
unit vector.
Some people even go so far
as to define the directional
derivative to be this, to be
something where you normalize
out the length of that vector.
I don't really like that, but
I think that's because they're
thinking of the slope context,
they're thinking of rates of
change as being the slope of a graph.
One thing I'd like to
emphasize as always, graphical
intuition is good, and visual
intuition is always great,
you should always be trying
to find a way to think about
things visually, but with
multivariable functions,
the graph isn't the only way.
You can kind of more generally
think about just a nudge
in the v direction, and in
the context where v doesn't
have a length 1, the nudge
doesn't represent an actual size
but it's a certain scaling
constant times that vector,
you can look at the video on
the formal definition for the
directional derivative, if
you want more details on that.
But I do think this is actually
a good way to get a feel for
what the directional
derivative is all about.